[Musique]
bonsoir soir à arlon rasseoir redit le
mène à rien de le dire
vous êtes très élégant c'est vrai très
en beauté pour les césar c'est pas pour
les seniors j'ai même pas le coffret ce
portois redon assez gentil fallait pas
et ça te plaît ouais ouais ouais c'est
ces gourmands cette couleur c'est quoi
ces deux rouges des trains ça fait pas
too much non non non non ça tombe bien
parce que je suis chez sun shine tu vois
ses angles rochoir magenta et je vois
pas tes frayer mais faut pas que tu
marches sur l'or parce que j'ai laissé
un chèque de caution et moi j'suis pas
solvables comme hutois ok ok ok je vais
pas vivre heureux bien sûr que je vais
faire très attention c'est promettre le
le césar ouais le montage pour un film
est une étape capitale sur m6 capital
c'est sur m6 et le dimanche soir demandé
vendredi l' on ne se rend pas compte en
tant que spectateur tout le travail que
ça demande aussi un frère ont matière à
4 des quatre grosses détail sa mère
ce que je viens de banlieue donc j'ai
dit sa mère voilà d'entrée voilà alors
parfois le film se construit au montage
moi aussi je suis en construction frère
c'est super bon